when you request a URL and hit enter the
browser sends a request to the server
for example we can simulate this right
on the command line once the browser
receives the response which is the HTML
we see here it must somehow convert all
of the mark-up into something that we
see on the screen here ever wonder how
that happens you know now that you
mention it it does feel a little bit
like magic
it's not magic the browser follows a
well-defined set of steps and it all
starts with processing the HTML and
building the Dom the HTML specification
contains a set of rules for how we
should process the received data for
example the text contained within the
angle brackets has special meaning in
HTML and is set to be a tag as a result
whenever we encounter attack the browser
emits a token in this case it is the
start tag HTML token next we would get
the start tag head token and so on this
entire process is done by the tokenizer
and while the token azor is doing this
work there's another process that is
consuming these tokens and it's
converting them to node objects for
example we convert the first HTML token
and create the HTML node then we consume
the next token and create the head node
is there a relationship between the
nodes yes
notice that the tokenizer emits start
and end tokens which tells us the
relationship between the nodes the start
tag head token comes before an tag HTML
token which tells us that the head token
is a child of HTML similarly the meta
and Link nodes are children of the head
node and so on
eventually once we consume all of the
tokens we arrive at the document object
model or simply Dom which is a tree
structure that captures the content and
properties of the HTML and all the
relationships between the nodes cool so
we've converted the HTML to the document
object model it's pretty easy to see why
it's called the Dom tree yeah also note
that these objects contain all of their
properties for example the image node
has a source attribute and this node
right here would also have the same
property the Dom is the full parsed
representation of the HTML markup
so we downloaded all the HTML and built
it on got it alright what's next
actually the browser constructs the Dom
incrementally and you can take advantage
of this to speed up the rendering of
your pages in fact this is something
that the Google search pages do really
really well let me show you